few comments and a question first I want
to thank you for for your advice last
time I was on your show um I was you
know having a bit of the baby rabies as
a guy and you kind of helped set me
straight about you know waiting for the
right situation Ken Rises to the top and
you know deal with that then and that
really helps settle me since that time
I've actually gotten involved as a
teacher so now I teach uh five through
nine year olds and it's definitely it's
scratched the itch that I had so I'm
totally good and I just want to again
thank you for your advice on that um the
other comment I'll add I I missed the
beginning part of your show but I caught
the tail in about mentorship and I just
like to say you know I was a managing
director um in the finance world and
definitely had people underneath me and
um and you're absolutely right people
who are hungry to just to be involved
those are the best and I and as a man
you know managing director I pour as
much into them as I can in terms of
Knowledge and Skills and I give them as
much opportunity as they can take so you
know your tips are spot on for anyone
else who's listening I that's the way to
go if you're looking for
mentorship um the question I have for
you is um I guess a female question um
so a little bit off topic from
entrepreneurship but I've become
involved with a woman and um the
relationship is actually going really
well um I have unique circumstances
because right now at the time I'm I'm
living in a uh basically a commune in a
sense so it's a bit of a challenge for
me she lives on the outside but she
comes and and visits um and I'm gonna
move out of here I think I'm moving to
Asia she wants to come with the
relationship's going well she's entering
my frame she's you know she's useful in
so many ways um everything's great but
there are a couple you know sort of like
red flags I mean she does have a child
this is a longdistance situation as it's
as it is right now we've been kind of
where do you live and where does she
live I live in Tennessee she lives in
Illinois which is where I used to live I
actually knew her for several years
before I moved here but then when I
would go I go to Chicago you know from
time to time every few months and I just
hit her up when I'm there and then she
started coming down here to see me so we
see each other every couple months and
it's just been kind of a loose thing but
this has been going on for a while now
and so it's starting to coales and I
just wanted to get your take on that if
you know I've heard you say other things
that you know you look at the red flags
it's going be hard to find someone
that's completely clean on them but if
there's one or two you know assess it
closely so I just want to get your take
on that um you know what it's like she
she's a bit older than me actually so
that idea how old are she I'm 40 she's
49 um that's just I know I know you want
to have
kids that's what I'm saying not really
you know with your advice and then now
teaching you know and being with all
these kids kids all the time it's
definitely scratch the itch I don't have
any personal need for like a personal
Legacy that's just I'm not interested in
that kind of stuff I just want to enjoy
my life you know and I enjoy being
around kids and and I've known her her
child since the child was like four or
five so I've known this woman for like
six years we just started getting
involved about a year ago but um that's
that's the situation I was just
wondering you know your thoughts on it
um I know it's limited for you to know
but yeah well okay so what are the red
flags so let's start with that cuz you
said something about that earlier yeah
basically you know she does have a child
um with another man but she got she was
you know around approaching you know the
wall the 40 and he was like I want to
have a child so she had a child with a
guy that she knew but knew he was never
going to be her husband and so it was
almost an intentional I'm GNA like
co-parent with this man and and so they
do co-parent they don't live together
they split time the kid at this point is
11 I mean like what's your goal here
like what are you trying to do with this
uh relationship so I don't really
actually let's just set aside this
relationship what are you looking for
for yourself you know putting yourself
first yeah putting myself first I'm
looking for someone who can you know uh
augment my life and my lifestyle you
know um share experiences with but also
do things you know that either I don't
have time to do or don't have the skill
set to do you know she mends my clothing
cleans my place every time she comes
over she starts cleaning um you know
she's very useful and there's other
things like that we have in common that
I see that we can do together um so it's
just an augment so in general that's
what I'm looking for an augment to my
life just to kind of enhance what's
already there because I'm content as I
am my I guess the reason I'm asking this
question is is is I'm trying to
understand should I cut this loose even
though it's great like there's really no
problems at all you know occasionally
she you know might planning on moving
too you said you you said something
about going to
Asia yeah I'm looking to uh to you know
buy a place in in Asia relocate have
another base of operations there here in
the US just kind of split time back and
forth and she's very interested in that
in in joining me on that um what does
she do for a living she cuts hair she's
which is another probably another red
flag I don't know being a hairdresser
it's one of those um so you got a
49-year-old hairdresser with an
11-year-old
kid pretty much yeah I know that's
that's why I'm asking I I needed a sober
assessment I mean I wouldn't touch it
with a 10- foot
pole so why would you settle for
it um BEC because she really her desire
for me is very strong it's very very
strong and and Okay so I want to pick
women who want me as opposed to no I get
it yeah no th% like I always say you
know make sure she's got gbd right gen
burning desire uh you know choose women
that choose you you know sort of thing
but if you're going to be going back and
forth from the states to Asia and she
wants to come along with you guess who
else is coming along with you the kit so
you're paying for her because she's not
going to have money to pay for flights
cuz she's a hairdresser you're going to
pay for her kid a child that's not yours
doesn't have your name doesn't have your
DNA you're raising another man's kid
basically a cuck old right at that point
like I talked about in my book yeah no
that's not the case because that's the
whole Asia thing's not going to happen
until this child is grown and out like
I'm gonna go there okay so you're
talking like in nine 10
years well yeah like seven years once
she gets and you know yeah I mean if
you're going to Asia why don't you just
get something over
there I I can I have it's it's
relatively easy to do it's just
um I found with the cultural differences
like I've been in relationships with
people who are not you know American and
it's great is an American or
she she's she's an she's an American
100% American but she happens to be of
of Asian ethnicity oh okay so you like
Asian women no I like all women this
just happens to be the flavor you know
got it time yeah I mean yeah it might
seem nice and comfortable and easy right
now you know she cleans your house and
she's in your frame and she's got
genuine wording desire and you know like
all all that sort of stuff but as you
start
to intertwine your lives together and
you and you travel and you do things she
she's going to expect you to do things
and pay for things for this child that
isn't yours and things won't be getting
better you know when you're spending
more time together and involving her kid
into the relationship they're going to
get a lot more complex I mean I think
you said you read my book twice
right I no I didn't say that I actually
haven't read your book at all sorry it
was smart sorry it was Rob that said
that he was a previous caller read my
book twice three times there's a chapter
in there on single mothers and
everything you need to understand when
it comes to dealing with single moms and
why they're not ideal um to sum it up
basically you are going to have respons
like parental responsibility to her
child and you're probably not going to
have much if any authority over that kid
you're going to have a lot of
expectations of you as you start to
intermingle your lives right but you
know your your uh boundaries and
anything that you want to enforce or if
you want to put yourself first in some
regard um it's always going to come back
to her and you know this kid it's just
not ideal right like if you can get a
woman that doesn't have a child in toe
you're going to be far far better off
you're going to have a lot more freedom
you're going to have a lot more like
there's women out there that don't have
a ten and red flags that are also uh
like don't have children or dude's kids
you know and toe um can you do it sure
but your life will become a lot more
complex unnecessarily before mine will
right right like I'm I'm with a gal
that's younger than me and she doesn't
have any kids you're talking about a kid
that's or a woman that's older than you
and she's got kids and she's got a very
low low paying job right so you're going
to be on the hook for taking care of her
and this kid as well right I don't know
what a hairdresser gets paid you know in
her state but I'm assuming it's like
what 30 35,000 a year not
much well I I hear what you're saying
I'm not disputing any of it and I'm
aware of that risk so for those reasons
I have not done been involved with her
child in that regard at all like I I set
that boundary I'm not you know doing
that and she doesn't me or want keep
that keep that boundary firm thing so if
you want to keep dealing with her make
sure that's an absolute firm bound like
I have friends right now that are
involved with single mothers and they're
like Rich love your [__] read your book
d d sort of thing right but they will
not and they have no interest in meeting
their kids their family doing
Thanksgiving Christmas or any of that
stuff with them they're like it's a firm
line you know we're dating we're seeing
each other you know we're having fun
that's it it's never going to happen
right so that's that's one way to see if
she's really in your frame and if she
really has genuine burning desire to see
if she'll Overlook it because most women
will be
like I kind of want him to get involved
with all this over here and I want like
the whole package I just don't want to
to date I just don't want to go over and
have sex and clean up his apartment or
whatever
right okay I uh it's just not ideal yeah
I know that's why I'm asking I um
because most of the women I date are
younger and um but there's a there's a
term in the um in Japan where moving to
uh when you date a woman that's slightly
older than you it's called a Golden
Slipper yeah because they they do so
much to care for you which is really
nice because she fits right into my
frame and but um but I agree it's not
ideal so you know I let me just say like
one more thing this going to be a little
bit harsh I mean there's a meme floating
around out there talking about Asian
women and when they hit menopause I
don't know if you've seen it no I have
not hang on let me see if I can find it
hold on a second Asian women there it is
it's kind of off to the side over
here does it get no it doesn't get any
bigger we'll do it like
that 18 20 to 30 30 to 50 you know she's
looking hot then it's like bang this is
what you're going to
get okay she's 49 she is not far from
that
yeah I hate to say it but you know like
I'm not here to fluffy up with rainbows
and butterflies and lie to you so I'm
just telling you the truth man like they
you know they don't age well right like
when they when they hit that they hit it
hard I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out